okay I'll take this one honestly I'm not
a big fan of Hagrid so
[Music]
hello Internet my name is Sarah and
welcome to fan er failure
the show where pop culture fans fight to
prove their devotion I am a huge Harry
Potter fan it's the book that got me in
two books I listened to the audio books
once a year I used to write fanfiction
I'm also worried that my friends and
family care about this a lot and they
might just sue me if I don't win if you
get a question right you get a point if
you get a wrong you have to read an
incredibly disparaging sentence about
Harry Potter let's get started
what is the name of the company where
Vernon Dursley works is it bloom turns
tunning threatens org runnings ha ha oh
my handwriting's quite nice today all
right let's see your answers those are
both correct you've avoided humiliation
for the first question how much money do
you need to include a hot chocolate with
your night bus ticket is it 13 sickles
29 nuts for sickles or six galleons I
have no ideas
for hot chocolate for hot chocolate on
the night bus I don't have some nuts Oh
1 2 3
Oh unfortunately unfortunately you're
both wrong what you're both wrong it was
13 sickles no expensive hot chalk that's
super expensive
oh you're selecting one for me Donald
Trump reminds me of Dumbledore Twilight
is a better story than Harry Potter
weird you'd say that
here's your next question folks
Wolfsbane and monkshood are technically
the same plan what does that plan called
is it called aconite tanzanite mela
night or Baffin I can tell you what it
does instead no you must choose a name
there's no option eat all right I think
one two three let's see those boards
it looks like Robin is Kermit it is
aconite 1000 fortunately that does mean
you have to read a horrible sentence
about the thing you love
if the sorting hat were real it would
sort these books into the trash where
they belong
this next game is called whose eyes are
these I'll show you three pictures of
eyes that I have drawn because I
couldn't get the rights to use the
actual photos and you guys will tell me
whose eyes are these
and unfortunately the punishment for
this is not saying disparaging sentences
about Harry Potter
it is however ripping pages from the
book no way No so pray that you know
whose eyes are these are those eyebrows
or is that these are eyebrows come on mo
you can't tell I'm offended ha ha it's
from the movie the books of words
there's no pictures you're pretty good
artists thank you whose eyes are these
no these are the eyes of Luna Lovegood
no they're not they a hundred prophetic
are and now it's time for your phone
just rip out a page you thought maybe Oh
JK Rowling's editor should have told her
shorten this chapter it's too long goes
on too long
alright professor my god I was getting
mad at Harry and Ron and Hermione that
happens like 20 times that's so wrong
okay I'll take this one
honestly I'm not a big fan of Hagrid so
whose eyes are these are their pupils
meant to be like Oh No
I messed up haha let's see him it's
unfortunately neither oh it was Remus
Lupin
the other law that was gonna unless I
want to oh yeah sometimes second choice
is the better choice oh this is when
Hagrid got drunk and got a dragon egg
I'm gonna worry about child abuse pages
from when he's living with the tersely I
love those bits
all right this is the last set of eyes I
have here whose eyes are these and it's
like a main character it's not like
madam hooch or something no it's not
it's not an obscure strange person I
haven't got the faintest idea
let's see those answers on one two three
unfortunately those are both wrong these
were the eyes of never long Bob no way
they were indeed his eyes he has
iversity Casey can you see it again it
is unfortunately that is the end of our
game however it does mean that Robin is
the winner that he is the greatest
wizard in all the lands and he wins the
golden Critch this is a lemon
[Music]